millions of Americans hitting the road
for Thanksgiving could have an
unpleasant surprise 28 percent of new
cars do not have a spare tire safety
advocates say many drivers have no idea
it's not in their cars
triple-a anticipates more than 330
thousand calls for roadside assistance
this week nearly 50,000 calls will be
for a spare tire Kris Van Cleave is in
Washington a lot of those drivers will
be in for a rude awakening Chris well
good morning you know the spare tire is
one of those standard features in cars
for decades but increasingly now when
you go to the trunk you'll find the spot
where the tire might go but no spare
tire so if this car gets a flat we're
going to be on the side of the road
waiting for a tow so there's no spare
tire in here a flat tire stranded
Michelle Stevens on the side of the road
for hours because her 2014 Cadillac
doesn't come with a spare that's not fun
you have a lot of people honking and
yelling at you and you tighten up
traffic when everybody wants to get to
work cuz usually that's when that
happens is during rush hour traffic and
there's nothing you can do about it
because you didn't have a spare tire to
fix it right exactly
in an effort to improve fuel economy and
car makers have looked to reduce weight
swapping the spare for an inflator kit
like this one that can patch small holes
space worse ago triple-a says 28% of new
2017 models are sold without a spare as
standard equipment in 2006 just five
percent came without a spare the list
includes cars for more than two dozen
auto brands from economy to luxury
though some pricier cars do come with
so-called run flat tires the truth is
most people don't know what's in their
trunk until that moment of need the auto
clubs John Nielsen says last year
triple-a answered more than 450,000
calls from drivers without a spare tire
if the repair kit in the trunk can't fix
the flat those drivers are facing a long
delay and a tow to a tire shop our
numbers show that that it is pretty rare
that the inflator kit can actually get a
flat tire back on the road do you worry
about hitting a pothole or something and
being stuck in this situation all over
again I do a little bit I mean it is
crosses my mind every once in a while I
tried to dodge the potholes when I see
them coming up but sometimes it's it's
hard not to see them they sneak up on
you Cadillac says they put installer or
inflator kits I should say in all other
vehicles and they do make small spares
available triple-a acknowledges they'd
still get calls about flat tires
regardless because about one in five of
us don't actually know how to change a
tire
gaile that is I was a Kris you took the
words out of my mouth I'm thinking I
don't actually know I've never done that
Thank You Kris Van Cleave well call me
Gayle out know where I live Thank You
Kris Van Cleave do you guys know how to
change it have you ever changed I have I
have very badly but you know okay I have
that you know you change the tire call
triple-a I don't have a call need a car
too